but there really is hope on the way i
believe that
welcome to cbs this morning that's where
we're going to begin with what president
biden called light
in the darkness in the fight against the
coronavirus it's coming in his first
primetime speech to the nation
he says by may 1st just 50 days from now
every adult american every adult
american got to say that twice
will be eligible to receive the vaccine
more than 64 million americans have
already had at least one dose
and that's around 25 of the adult
population the president also laid out
the benefits of what he calls his
american rescue plan for the u.s economy
and said americans should remain
vigilant against the virus
ed o'keefe is at the white house for us
ed good morning to you there was grief
in the speech last night but also
hope would stood out to you with the big
message absolutely tony good morning a
call for national unity and cooperation
he's optimistic about the coming months
but laid out in stark terms what he
thinks americans need to do
to help fight the pandemic keep wearing
masks socially distance and get a
vaccine when you can
and while the country is starting to
look ahead to the coming months the
president took time last night to
remember
the hundreds of thousands of lives lost
finding light in the darkness is a very
american thing to do in fact
it may be the most american thing we do
president biden set
two new goals on two key dates all
adults
people 18 and over eligible to be
vaccinated
no later than may 1. and july 4th
independence day if we do our part
if we do this together by july the 4th
there's a good chance you
your families and friends will be able
to get together in your backyard or in
your neighborhood
and have a cookout at a barbecue and
celebrate independence day
the president said he's deploying active
duty military fema personnel
and retired doctors to help vaccinate
americans and he outlined what
should be possible for most americans in
the coming weeks
you can drive up to a stadium or a large
parking lot
get your shot never leave your car and
drive home in less than an hour
but he was also reverential as he paid
tribute to lives lost
reading the exact democratic card in my
pocket 527
726 off a card he pulled
from his pocket they leave behind loved
ones
unable to truly grieve or to heal even
to have a funeral
the president made a point to denounce
an uptick in attacks against asian
americans since the start of the
pandemic
so many of them are fellow americans
they're on the front lines of this
pandemic trying to save lives
and still still they're forced to live
in fear
for their lives just walking down
streets in america
it's wrong it's an american and it
must stop the speech came just hours
after mr biden signed the nearly two
trillion dollar
american rescue plan into law
thank you all appreciate it and now he
the vice president
and their spouses plan to travel to at
least six states in the coming days
to sell the plan one of the states the
president and vice president will visit
together
is georgia next friday that states two
new democratic senators were key
to getting the american rescue plan
passed and as you saw there
he officially signed the bill yesterday
but they'll hold a ceremonial swearing
or a swearing-in signing ceremony for
the bill today
in the rose garden it'll be a smaller
event to adhere to social distancing
amid the pandemic but we noticed
something there are at least 22
lawmakers
invited to attend